this is Sean Evans checking in from the
fireplace which means that it's time for
another story and this is the shocking
exciting somewhat depressing but
important story about life a story about
my first kiss now to start we have to
take things all the way back to seventh
grade when I was a chubby faced kid with
a bowl cut but you know it's funny about
life especially at that time of life as
things can change in a single weekend
and I'm telling you in one weekend my
jaw line snapped into place and I got a
98 degrees haircut and I came back to
Hannah Beardsley middle school in it was
a totally different place after that
weekend I don't know what happened I'm
walking down the hall girls are giggling
it's a totally different experience for
me and I'm I have no way of dealing with
it it's all happening so fast that's
it's funny about that time in life
seventh grade I'll never forget it I was
like I started a whole new life just
cutting my damn skater cut anyway there
was a place that everybody in my middle
school used to go on the weekends it was
the Studio 54 for junior high kids it
was called spikes and I don't know how
this business work exactly because kids
would just swarm spikes it was like a
big roller rink volleyball courts but
more than anything it was a place where
every young rite of passage took place
your first fight probably had spikes
your first hit of some weed probably at
spikes the first time you touched a boob
probably at spikes it was the most
exciting club scene that I've ever been
part of and I don't think anything in my
life can change that all right some of
the names here have been changed to
protect the innocent because these
aren't people that I still talk to so
it's not like I can pick up the phone
and be like hey dude I haven't talked to
you since like junior high but is it
cool if I put you in a YouTube video
with like millions of users or whatever
not gonna do that so some of the names
have been changed to protect the
innocent but I had a
let's call him Tom Whittier and he was
like 20 when he was in seventh grade he
had like older brothers and like had a
vibe like it wouldn't be surprised like
if he came and like picked me up in a
car it was just like one of those junior
high kids that was older so he was
dating an eighth grader from the town
over and Carrie and that was a big deal
because the Carrie was like supposedly
had like hotter girls or something I
don't know but that seemed like a world
that I couldn't even touch until one day
at spikes when Tom comes running over to
me and he says hey that girl over there
thinks you're cute and I look over and I
see a cool popular super hot
eighth-grade girl that I'd like the
reputation had preceded her I knew she
wasn't like oh my god and Here I am now
overwhelmed with this new life I had I
went from a bowl cut and the goofball
lunch table to all of a sudden promoted
a popular guy table I'm walking on air
it's a whole new existence and guess
what I'm liking my new pair of shoes I'm
getting used to it I'm liking it we go
to a basketball game that week it goes
great and then the idea gets floated for
movie night a double date
Tom Whittier his eighth grade girlfriend
me my new eighth grade girlfriend things
are taken off we're down in the basement
we got VHS is on deck we watch one
horror movie and the whole time
tom has posted up with this girl like
he's a young Joe Namath like he's done
it every day of his life now I look back
on it I that's the thing I respect most
about him is he had this underlying
confidence he could just post up with
this chick meanwhile I'm just sitting on
the couch stiff she's right next to me
kind of like what's up with this guy and
they even the girls had a little powwow
in between movies like Shawn is being
weird and then Tom ed talked to me like
dude put your arm around her man so
before the next movie she's coming back
with some popcorn and as she's sitting
down I just real quickly went like
and she like boom cuddled in and I'm
like all right I'm in I'm now piloting
this ship we watched the movie and then
at the end I'm like all right I'm going
in and I go in for a big smooch the
first smooch of my life and it felt
great mom comes up the driveway to pick
us up hop in the van go home
and I'm on cloud nine I can't believe it
I'm in love I've changed I've grown up
I'm now a man can't wait to see the guys
at school on Monday so on Monday things
seem a little bit odd like everyone's in
on a joke that I don't know or something
and that really hit a fever pitch at
lunch when I'm sitting there and
everyone's kind of giggling and laughing
around me and that's where a guy will
call him Todd Beaver stands up and goes
hey Who am I takes a bite out of his
Apple Oh spits out the one part and just
starts going and the whole table is
laughing and laughing and laughing and
all of a sudden I can see that they're
laughing at me
apparently I would just went way too
hard tone going like crazy she was like
wow this seventh-grade dork has no idea
what he's doing not picking up my calls
the next day I thought everything's okay
now I'm being ghosted I've lost my
girlfriend now all my new friends are
all goofing on me all laughing at me and
now that I look back on it I'm like Todd
what were you you're in seventh grade to
like what do you have cooking like at
least I'm making out with a girl the
worst part of it was there was like
three tag-along friends that I was able
to promote to the cool guy table and I'm
looking at them like hey guys you think
you're staying at this table once I get
kicked out like we're all at we're a
package deal like I brought you guys up
with me like we're going back to
triple-a tomorrow like pack your bags
and get on the bus so here I am
humiliated low I lose my girl I'm being
made fun of embarrassed by all of my
new friends I'm down I'm as low as I can
be I remember sitting in the front yard
staring up at the night sky listening to
Dave Matthews Band and just being like
does the world not understand me or do I
not understand the world but you know
what bounced back the next year and
dated the tallest girl in school
that's a comeback story and that's the
story of my first kiss now if you guys
have been following the series you know
that it's tradition to kick it to a
foreign film recommendation and today
I'm so excited to bring in a guest
recommendation camera guy bill what
foreign films should the people check
out I can't wait for my first kiss
what an inspiring story Sean what is up
cam Pham camera guy built in his
apartment ready to list some of my
favorite foreign film recommendations
for you let's get it on from Indonesia
the read Redemption the raid 2 from
France moon prophet Lehane Pierre yella
foo from the Dutch Borg man from Korea
memories of murder train to Busan from
Japan Bama rail from Sweden left the
right one in from Spain rekt 1 & 2 from
Germany the baader-meinhof complex the
lives of others from the UK kill list
and from Greece dogtooth oh I hope that
satisfies your cinema tastebuds this is
camera guy bill here saying it's okay to
watch movies with subtitles and it's
good to be camera guy bill
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans checking in to give you
the origin story behind Los calientes
Rojo so a few months back we decided to
go completely bizarro world and went dr.
Frankenstein on all of our sauces and
and started mixing and matching the
peppers and just put it out thought it
would be a stupid one-time thing but we
accidentally threw that science
experiment created one of the greatest
sauces of all time Louis calientes Rojo
get your bottle at Heat inist Heat nest
com2 get a bottle of Lowe's calientes
Rojo Lowe's calientes Rojo accidentally
delicious
[Music]
you